that script i remember reading it and i
got very emotional about it and that's
really hard to do
it's really hard to get an emotional
reaction from a script
when you worked at these production
companies interning out of the hundred
screenplays
how many were awful
uh
i'd say about
more than 90 percent percent are awful
or no i mean mean i'd say more than 90
are bad
um
maybe 40 are awful
i mean because i mean you got to get
people credit
really bad scripts don't necessarily
make it up the ladder
because
you got assistance and their job is
they're gatekeepers precisely so
um what i mean scripts are bad
it doesn't necessarily mean they're
badly written it means that
you know they're conventional full of
cliches
um
maybe you know maybe they stick to genre
and um
and they don't transcend it in any way
lazy in terms of ideas
but i mean that doesn't mean that
doesn't mean they're not potentially
commercial products
so i don't think that
people in charge of choosing don't have
any taste or or can't discern what i
think is that you know they're trying to
find something that sells
and if you check netflix 10 most watched
shows or
they're not necessarily good
again i'm not trying to be
the judge of what's good or bad i mean
i try to be entertained but also
stimulated and i want to think and i
want to feel i mean
some people just need you know come back
from work they hate what they do and
they want to watch something that takes
their mind off it and
it works
sure and there are some networks that
cater to that and they have very
predictable stories and outcomes and and
people feel safe in watching that that's
what they want
it is it is a business and and um i
think most of the people involved in in
show business are very smart
um
i'm i don't think execs are you know
like bureaucrats i think they're some of
them went to you know harvard and yale
and whatever and they're really educated
and smart it's just it's a business
so
you know most of the shows big networks
are gonna put up are probably
easy to digest
sure
i i get it it's not what i watch but
then again i don't represent the larger
population
that's a good point so
the ones that were really awful probably
wouldn't have made it that far in the
process but you say 40 ish
maybe were bad
so then
60 were great or
then
there was a gray area where some were
not horrible no the percentage of great
scripts is really small
so great i mean
let's say good
let's say
i mean i'm generalizing let's say
between eight to ten percent of the
scripts are actually good
great
maybe two percent okay one percent wow
it's really hard to find a great script
it's really hard to write a great script
um
that's why cern you know
i don't know shonda rhimes did grey's
anatomy it's what it's the 14th 15th
season
of course then eventually she came up
with other shows but she's been work she
was working on that show for many years
and that was one
great script that got it all started
it's really hard to replicate success
you know some people
the simpsons right yeah sure they did
futurama and you know some other
attempts but the sims are the simpsons
so it's really really hard to write a
great script it's really hard to to find
the people willing to take risks to
produce it and get it made
queen's gambit you know big success what
last year it took 10 years to get that
made
i remember meeting the the guy who wrote
dallas buyers club that movie took 20
years to get made
i'm not saying that's okay and i'm not
saying that's the standard i'm saying
you got to be ready to know that things
take a long time
unless unless you want to go out there
and make a really small movie
self-financed or through you know
crowdfunding or something like that
which isn't easy either
um and a lot of people do it and hope
that it clicks you know and
i can i can think of the examples where
that helped um
what's it called a woman walks home at
night
alone yeah alone at night so um
she was at ucla before i i was in uh um
i remember the director's name lily um
iranian so um she went out there and
made that movie and it got an audience
and she has a career and good for her
yeah
or lilly yes so you know a few examples
like that um
[Music]
but even you know back in the day
sundance was like the way in and now
sundance is so commercial and so
oversaturated
that if you make a movie by yourself i
mean i don't even know if you can find a
spot
there
yeah it's probably become a much
different uh
ballgame and then some of those movies
then play other festivals and it's kind
of like all the same movies
going to these festivals and it's
yeah
i mean i'm i don't even want to get into
the whole sure we don't have to because
um
you know as as a former film critic i
know that world very well
uh and i have opinions about festivals
but um yeah we can stay away i get it no
i look i think that um
writing a good script takes a couple of
not even months i'd say a year or maybe
two of rewrites
um
maybe know you know what you want to say
and then you can get it done in six
months
i don't know
would you read every one of those
screenplays from start to finish
when i when i had to read them yeah when
you're working as an intern at these
products uh yes
yes i um
well first of all i had to
um because when you do coverage
coverage basically exists so the people
above you don't have to read those
scripts unless they have to
so what you're doing is you're
summarizing you have to give them a log
line
a synopsis
maybe a short synopsis and then a longer
one of the story of the whole story
um
and then
say the pros and cons and you know and
and choose if you're
passing or considering or recommending
and of course everyone's really scared
to recommend because then your taste and
your job is on the line
right
so you got to be re most of the times
you'll say pass
and this you know
because
you really want to make sure if you
recommend something it's that good
uh i as an intern i did take chances
though and there were no consequences
but it it would happen that they would
come to me and say okay so tell me more
what did you see in it i want to hear
you you know so
um you got to have an opinion
and by the way this is really helpful as
a writer it is but if if you want to be
an exec someday or a producer you better
have opinions and you better be able to
express them
in an articulate way
as a writer not so much i did it i did
it to learn mostly and get experience
so you were working with producers would
they also then read the script from uh
back to front or front if you can if you
suggest they consider it or even if you
recommend it
maybe not themselves their assistants
will i don't know
necessarily but um
you're basically saving them time
[Music]
but if you waste their time you won't be
there much longer
because if they have to read and hate it
and this is you know it's part of the
business
sure what if your tastes are just edgier
and you like something that's more of an
art film and they're looking for a
feel-good relationship story well i
would say is if you're entering a
company do your research on their
mandate
so you know if they do horror and you're
and and they get for any number of
reasons
you know
a romantic story with no horror
whatsoever
because you never know
maybe maybe the the son of someone they
know wrote the script and sent it i
don't you never know how that works
it's not for them you know it's not
their mandate
unless you can ask them like hey i got
the script that's really weird it's not
really your mandate do you want me to go
on with it and they'll say yes please
read it anyway i see so you're going to
check if something is not sort of in
their wheelhouse you'll check with them
you should be yeah so blumhouse right
that's horror everyone knows that so if
you have a you know thriller with spies
it might be a great script it's probably
not and and by the way blumhouse doesn't
spend more than three to five million
per movie
so you got to do your homework
you know they're not the right
company for
it maybe it's a great script and you
tell them hey by the way this is not
your mandate but it's a great script
okay we'll send it over to our friends
somewhere else and they owe us a favor i
don't know
you know but it makes you look good to
know what their mandate is
sure sure but if you're recommending
stuff that's just
then they're going to sit you down and
you know
why are you setting us up it didn't
happen to me
i'm just imagining i mean sure
um
you got to know what your role is as
well you know
and as an intern you don't have a lot of
power
how many of the screenplays that you
read went on to be films
um
less than 10
probably um
some of them this is the thing some of
them i
i knew were already gonna get made uh
some of them you know you knew you knew
they were going around town so it's not
like only the production company had
that script
uh and you could tell you know i
remember there was a script about the
kelly gang in australia
um
that movie was obviously ready to get
shot
i mean it was so well i don't even know
what they they made me read it maybe
because they wanted to invest in it um
but it didn't feel like someone sent
that you know inspect that was ready to
go
um
[Music]
i'm trying to remember
there were amazing scripts i read that
didn't get made and i'm surprised
oh you know which script i read and i
haven't seen the movie yet the one with
um
michael keaton worth that just came out
recently about the 911 lawyer i read
that script oh yes that was great so i
read that script in uh 2016.
we just watched that and they just got
right it got made 2020 i think
right yeah that was so you know
between four to five years
that's not that bad actually
but you know it takes a while
so you said there were a few that were
excellent that didn't get made
yeah i'm
i'm trying to remember i remember an
amazing script about uh anne frank and
um
[Music]
the woman in new york who got the book
published
uh for the first time in the 40s i think
or
maybe early 50s so how the
[Music]
the manuscript was discarded at first
and this this junior editor woman who
she wanted to become an editor the woman
who discovered the book and said hey
wait a minute
this is actually uh relevant
um
that script i remember reading it and i
got very emotional about it and that's
really hard to do
it's really hard to get an emotional
reaction from a script
i mean
if you can make people laugh with a
script that's a lot if you can make
people teary-eyed
wow
that's very unique
i remember that script very well
because i was at work you know i was
just i was about to break into tears and
i'm like i'm i'm in an office i
shouldn't you know i shouldn't be crying
in public they're going to ask me if
something's wrong at home oh no it's the
script it's just so good
um no i mean i have tons of respect for
that writer and it was never made
not that i know off but i mean
sometimes it takes 10 years
hopefully it gets made